[Music]
shailen is in saskatchewan hi shaelyn
how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so my husband and i own a small
construction business and we are often
making
large material purchases upwards of ten
thousand dollars
so how do we do this without using
credit cards we're debt-free
personally and
with our business but where you use a
credit card to make business purchases
online and over the phone and we don't
have a problem with paying it off but we
want to get away from credit card so
what debit card do you recommend for
large online business purchases
you'll have to customize your debit card
with your local bank the way we have
because a large singular purchase won't
fly with most debit cards unless you've
got it set up most of them have pretty
stringent daily limits and single
purchase limits
and uh so but you can have that
customized like you know i don't walk
around with a debit card that's that's
limits me to a thousand bucks i mean i i
may buy something expensive because i've
got the money and so
obviously the relationship i have with
the bank allows me to do that and you've
got to do that with a good local bank
and set your debit card up and then
obviously you have to build up the
the uh business savings it's called
retained earnings
to build a cash flow this on behalf of
your clients until you get the money
back from them obviously when you're
ordering something you're passing that
cost on to your customer
and you're getting the money back after
as they pay a draw on the construction
or as they pay for the construction
project being completed one of the two
right
yeah yeah so you're just it's a 30-day
thing maybe
uh and so you know you're just gonna you
need up you need
prime the pump one time
if you had twenty thousand dollars cash
sitting in your business checking
account it just rolled over all the time
it would drain down some and then it
would come back up when you got paid and
then it would drain down some and then
it would come back up when you get paid
you just set a limit i don't go below 15
000 cash in my business retained
earnings because i need that much to
cash flow
these purchases and so on and so yeah it
may take you a little while to get there
uh the other thing we did because we
didn't have the money to to cover it in
the early days like that if we were
purchasing something here like
let's say we go and buy um
in the old days maybe we buy 10 000
copies of a book that we're getting
ready to sell
and then we ship those books out to
bookstores and we ship them out through
the distributors and it may be two three
months before we get paid on those
and so what we had to do was just go
ahead and you know build the money up to
pay for the order period
and then when the money came back in
off of the sale of those books it was as
if we uh
as if it was all free money you know
because we didn't have anything else we
won we never owed against it you know it
was a 100 check right we'd already paid
for the cost of goods sold i already
paid for the materials i've done a few
home projects over the years where the
builder comes and says here's what your
material costs are going to be to get
out the door to get started
and they required that up front yeah and
so i actually
gave them the money that way i'm not
going to walk and they're not so
and i've heard horror stories about that
where gc can walk off with your
pre-payment but i like that option too
yeah change your terms that's what i was
leading to was on the books we had to if
somebody wanted an unusually large order
that we couldn't cash flow we just had
to require a deposit of 50 up front and
that pays for the books and that
actually paid for more than the books it
paid for some more because we don't have
50 in them so
our cost of goods sold is not that high
and so we had to change the terms of
working with our customer but i love
that what you said about if you get 20
or 30 000 bucks in your account you
become your own bank yep and i love that
way of operating yeah and it's just it's
real clean i'll tell you the other thing
it's weird is
it it changes what you're buying and how
you're buying it
because it's like real money when you're
doing it with debt it doesn't feel like
it's real money but when you're pulling
your money out of your checking account
to make this purchase you're like uh
you have this moment where you just make
sure it's all right you measure to the
fence post yeah yeah and you don't think
about that when you're just slapping a
plastic down we get take over later just
get it let's get it we got to get this
going we got to get and you get sloppier
when you're using borrowed money
unless less wise